this is a production of Cornell
University
I know that you heard cybersecurity like
this is very different so I do I do two
very disparate things if you have
questions about cybersecurity or
blockchain that's sort of 90% of my real
job at Stanford I'm happy to answer
those as well and this is kind of a 10%
of my time where I wanted to get back
into protein engineering and so started
to work with GFI GFI is kind of a
think-tank we're a completely remote
organization and so we don't have lab
space of our own but we support
researchers at universities across the
world we fund some research and we work
with companies that are developing both
plant-based meat which is what I'll talk
to you about today and clean meat or
sell cultured meat part of the future of
replacing some of our animals so one of
our reasons for doing this in the first
place is that we project that we're
going to need to feed 10 billion people
by and the way that we currently use the
Earth's surface now in terms of how much
land is devoted to habitable land how
much ocean how much how much as for us
how much is used for agriculture how
much is used for livestock we think is
not going to be a sustainable way of
eating we think that particularly the
amount of cropland and you're not a
braising land that goes toward livestock
is a relatively inefficient use of those
resources and so you can kind of argue
over whether these population
projections are going to be accurate and
when I was giving a talk at the National
Academies Steven Chu was the former
Secretary of Energy was like no no I
think that humans have an internal kind
of like quorum sensing mechanism and
that were going to see population start
to decline because he thinks that people
are going to kind of look around and
realize that we're not using our
research as efficiently and like control
population I'm not sure that we're
seeing that happen it's hard to argue
it's hard to like kind of tell people
that things are going to be okay as long
as we just all decide to start having
fewer children because I've tried to
make that argument including at the
National Academies and people are like
oh it's too late we're already in our
mid 30s and 40s we have them already so
I think what we need to do is we need to
change the way that we're eating in the
way that we're feeding those people
because we kind of need to assume that
we are going to have more people in the
world who we are going to be to feed and
that this is going to be an inefficient
system so why is it an inefficient
system and from what kind of perspective
do we think of it as being inefficient
if we just look at it kind of
thermodynamically inputs to outputs how
many calories of feed need to go into
making an animal and then how many
calories of food can we get out of that
animal we see
the majority of the livestock that we
watch like all the livestock that we use
are inefficient and in fact some of the
primary you know more efficient species
we're not even talking about cows which
you know are inefficient large animals
some of the smaller animals that we grow
like pigs and chickens and fish are also
very inefficient and since that the
amount of calories in that are converted
to calories out is somewhere around 10
to 12 percent for cattle it's even lower
for cattle is below 10 it's 8% there are
some species of farmed fish that can get
you up to like 20 or 22 percent but the
way that they calculate that kind of
like the life cycle analysis of the
farmed fish in often cases in many cases
doesn't take into account the nutrients
that it's getting from the kind of
surrounding ocean that the farm is in so
a lot of like farmed salmon they'll do
off the coast of like me and they'll be
in these pens that are semipermeable
they are being able to get some
nutrients from the surrounding ocean
water and that's not taking into account
the LCA so that kind of sums up the
efficiency numbers um and actually
they're running out of coastline to make
farm salmon so the latest things that
they have bought companies are their
farming salmon have bought plots of land
in like Central Florida after they're
making just these incredibly large pens
on land filled with water kept very cool
will because salmon like a very cold
environments even in Florida there's
kind of like Ford really cool well you
know cool tanks that they're growing
farm salmon and so if you want to talk
about inefficiency and about the effects
on the environment not only do we
sometimes see that in farm fish we get
disease spread from the Pens into the
ocean because they're these semi
permeable pens if we're going to try to
grow fish that require cold water on
land then we're really getting into to
lower efficiencies and we think would be
optimal for being able to feed as many
people as we do so we can also talk
about in terms of then food waste we
know that food waste is a problem in
terms of recapturing nutrients that were
able to grow and produce and the amount
of food wasted by consumers or in the
supply chain is dwarfed in comparison to
the amount of food wasted in producing
chicken or beef as the most common
another way of look
that is that we devote quite a lot of
our land mammal population to our pets
and livestock as opposed to wild animals
we also see some habitat loss kind of
off target effects of growing this many
sheep goats pigs horses and cattle where
we're using a lot of land that could be
either used for crops or could be
preserved for natural environments using
it to grow livestock so if we think that
that's a problem then why do we see that
global demand for me is increasing
across all categories of meats based on
both US and global demand we see that
where we have increased demand for as
well as particularly increased demand in
fast-growing and populations in
developing economies part of the reason
for that is that as people get richer
they want to model their diets more on
traditionally Western diets they want to
eat more meat or me to see it as a
status symbol and so that's why we see
some of the highest growth rates in
terms of meat consumption
so we're projected to eat a lot more
meat by 2050 and particularly a lot more
chicken and that meat is going to have
to come from somewhere but hopefully it
doesn't have to come from the same
system that's being used to produce it
another thing I want to point out is
that we don't actually eat we don't
actually have like a protein deficit
we're eating much more protein than we
need particularly in wealthy regions for
some reason we're not all like buff and
muscle-bound so some of this protein is
just kind of going waste but if you look
at the average daily protein requirement
across different countries and how we're
meeting that requirement in many places
around the world we would be able to
meet all of that protein requirement
just with plant protein alone and not
need to take into account all the kind
of excess animal protein that we consume
so taking that into account we want to
look at the idea of whether we can
replace some of the animal-based protein
that people are using so what our
plant-based proteins okay like this
audience probably knows what those end
up becoming these are some of the
plant-based meat products and
plant-based dairy products that are
currently available it's anything from
replacing chicken and beef in the
sandwich to replacing cheeses other
types of plant-based dairy
even additives in to combine products or
you'll have some animal needs and some
plant-based meat that are - product we
want again to look back at plant
proteins as replacing animal proteins
because they're more sustainable they're
more sustainable in terms of land use in
terms of water consumption in terms of
greenhouse gas emissions beef is the
least efficient animal meat in terms of
land use but all animal meats the right
o - line perform worse in terms of all
of these categories than plant-based
foods do so if we want to transition
some of our protein consumption to more
sustainable proteins it kind of moves us
to look into plant proteins rather than
trying to optimize maybe the efficiency
of pork or farm fish there's a long
history of plant-based meat but the
history of kind of the directed
engineering of plant-based products
really happens in the last 15 or so
years with a Beyond burger and the
impossible burger which I'll talk about
newer products that these companies are
developing but my face meat we can kind
of trace back to some of the earliest
known meat substitutes things like tofu
and Yuba and tempeh are kind of in a
category unto themselves in the sense
that when we do market analyses we look
at like Nielsen spores of supermarket
sales in terms of plant-based meat
category they don't lump tofu or tempeh
or you buy into that category they think
them as a separate kind of a separate
product so we're talking about time
based meat sales we're talking only
about products that are like veggie
burgers or veggie sausage that are
specifically designed to replace a
particular meat components and not
something like tofu but we see
historically that tofu and like wheat
gluten and they were used to replace
meat products as far back as 1915 for
tempeh and Indonesia some of the then
not in peanut based meat substitutes
that were developed as well as tofu soy
based meat substitutes were aimed at a
religious audience an audience that
didn't want to eat meat either one day a
week or for other religious holidays and
these started to be commercialized by
John Kellogg and others at the start of
the 20th century the first u.s. meatless
burger the soy burgers for 1937
we see then the advent of textile
manufacturing tools to produce
dürdane spun soy protein fibers idiot
now we can take my proteins you can make
them into textures that look a bit more
like muscle fibers and that replicate
better the texture of piece of meat and
then we started to see more
commercialization Morningstar farms or
Fergie kind of the Boca burgers that you
might have been familiar with in the 90s
the FDA released in 1999 a statement
that consumption of soy protein may
reduce the risk of heart disease that
kind of improved marketing and
commercialization and then beyond me and
impossible foods were both founded in
the Bay Area both by chemists named
Browns they are frequently confused but
two separate companies they make the
beyond burger and the impossible burger
which they launched within about a year
of each other so all so confused but
well going to the differences between
them and kind of some of the strategy
behind making these kind of more
engineered plant protein burgers so a
lot of what GFI wants to do is support
companies to enter into this space and
also just support research in the space
and when we put out a call for proposals
for plant-based researchers well why
doing research on either you know
texturing of plant proteins extracting
plant proteins growing plants that have
higher concentrations of proteins the
way that we categorize it is in terms of
this mind map where we look at what goes
into making plant-based me everything
from sourcing a protein isolation and
functionalisation formulation processing
and the distribution and we look for
research that's going on in all of these
areas because we think that we're going
to need to have a process improvements
across all pieces of this mind map in
order to get to products that meet
consumer demand in terms of taste price
and convenience and are able to replace
some of the animal-based meat market so
starting with ingredient sourcing to
make fun based meat we have to have
plants provide all of the raw materials
and not just the protein to provide the
carbohydrates the fat flavorings I'll
talk a little bit later about why it's
particularly difficult to incorporate
plant-based fats into these products
when comparing it to something like
that's naturally present in beef or pork
so this can involve things like crop
engineering and breeding genomic trait
mapping to see which parts of the plant
genome correspond to higher protein
yields or high bioavailability of
protein and it also involves looking at
different sources of protein from things
like algae even from
plant sources like fungi that we usually
kind of just lump in with with plant
proteins when we look at what proteins
from plants are used in plant based meat
right now it's still predominantly soy
soy Qian wheat a kind of the three main
plant proteins that are used in plant
based products and soy overall its most
popular part of that is because soy is a
complete proteins when you look at
analyzing a plant protein you look at
the PD cast core that looks at the
concentrations of different amino acids
in that protein and you want something
that's as close to one as possible so
that it has whole it has all the
nutritional requirements of the amino
acids that we cannot synthesize
ourselves I Tara Lee and soy meats that
soy is is around point nine to one you
can reach a PDK score of one by
combining other plant proteins but that
kind of nutritional completeness of soy
protein is one of the main reasons why
soy is predominantly used a part of it
is also because plant proteins for a
long time were used or thought of as
kind of something that like a secondary
use of these crops and so we have a lot
of field space devoted to soy devoted to
weed devoted to core and to feed crops
are aiming to feed to feed livestock
into grows other sources and so that was
part of the reason also for why we used
these proteins even if they may not be
the ones that most closely mimic animal
proteins some of the studies that were
looking at are how nutrition profiles
vary across different grains where we
might be able to extract not only the
protein but also the fiber and the fat
from those grains to make more
ingredients available for fight based
meat so if you look at the macro
nutrient content in cereal grains we see
a variety of protein concentrations but
then also a broader range of variety in
terms of fiber fat or oil that's
available for extraction and then
similarly the micronutrient content even
among millets where there's a project
that we work with at Berkeley that's
trying to increase the cultivation of
millet and study with the availability
of protein in millet and also the millet
is a lot more commonly grown in Europe
not as much in the US the reason for
that that they find is that they try to
encourage farmers to switch over to
millet because there's not a strong
militant
u.s. they have trouble getting crop
insurance for it and then because they
can't insurance for they don't grow and
so it's kind of this catch-22 cycle of
trying to get people to switch over it
on a large scale to a new cereal crop
but some of the benefits then of trying
to extract protein from this crop is
that you can also get the subsidiary
benefit of having better micronutrient
contents from that crop and so if you
want a product that has a high iron
concentration because you know that iron
needs to kind of like a meaty taste
relieves to more like a bloody taste you
may want to have a crop that has higher
levels firing another way that we're
trying to study the variability in plant
proteins is through how environmental
conditions impact crop performance so
even if we're growing the same crop we
know that pH levels a nitrogen levels
can vary quite a bit and soil then we
may need to look at for example for pea
varieties how growing pea varieties in
in these different soil concentrations
affects the protein content which is
something that's usually not a part of a
general yield study so what we're trying
to do in supporting this research is to
optimize these crops to improve the raw
materials we want to improve the
nutrition and the functionality and the
performance of the plants that we're
using we want to improve the
bioavailability of the protein that
we're extracting we probably want to
improve the concentration of the protein
in that plant and we also want to do
that in a way that decreases cost so of
the projects that we support at these
various universities one of the ones
that's focus specifically on that that's
this one at Clemson University of this
characterizing field pea and sorghum
crops to try and improve the protein
content of them and improve the
nutrition for my based meat this is kind
of one of the first studies where
they're specifically selecting and
optimizing cultivars for protein extra
for protein extraction for plant-based
meat and for protein by a fortification
another one is looking at quinoa as a
raw material for plant-based meat
products trying to characterize and
optimize existing quinoa varieties and
optimize protein extraction methods
products so quinoa is cultivated around
the globe and it's considered to be
pretty resistant to abiotic about
expresses the average grain yield for
quinoa is two and a half to three and
half tonnes per hectare and then in the
last ten years this group have
conducted experiments to cultivate
quinoa in Israel and they've increased
that to an average grain yield of six
tonnes per hectare say thinking that
quinoa might be a more sustainable crop
in Israel than in other areas where it's
grown commercially valuable there
they're going to try to evaluate quinoa
as a sustainable source of protein
itself picking seeds from high yielding
quinoa accessions and characterizing
them for protein content content fiber
content looking at different extraction
methods to prepare the protein
concentrates
isolates fiber and defatted quinoa flour
from these in the raw materials that's
one of the projects in Israel there's
another company that we work with that's
an Israeli company economic rock reading
and strain development to improve
multiple traits simultaneously they were
founded six years ago to kind of a
breeding and seed development company
and what they're trying to look at is
ways of increasing protein concentration
in these plants as well as other things
like color and taste and amino acid
composition simultaneously so they've
done that with yellow pea in about three
years they increased the amount of
protein in the yellow peas during their
working with from sixteen to twenty
percent to twenty to thirty percent and
the seed they also have projects with
cowpea fava bean mung bean lentil quinoa
with the university that are funding it
in israel chickpea and sesame so they'll
just they'll collect as many kind of
cultivars and variants varieties as they
can you know type in phenotype them
algorithmically just simulate all the
potential crosses that they could do
with these varieties make those crosses
and then with kind of two or three
cycles per year look at which end up
having in this case higher protein
concentrations or better taste better
amino acid composition and iteratively
narrowing on which are going to be the
best process for in this case for
protein composition so it's not
particularly directed they're kind of
trying to make this entire field like a
matrix of all the potential across --is
that they can make with all the
varieties are available part the reason
for that is that some of the crops that
they're working with are poorly
characterized in terms of what improves
protein concentration and their jobs
trying to do this in a relatively short
timeframe so based on the success with
yellow pea we're working on them to try
to increase
protein concentrations and some of these
other varieties with hope that if we can
get the protein concentration in some of
these varieties up to the same level as
we see protein in in soybean for example
or in rice and wheat then we can start
to transition some of the use of soy so
these are some of the protein sources
that we look at with in terms of beauty
caste for in terms of functionality for
example do they extrude well are they
something that can be that has good like
with ability that can make kind of can
make good emulsification so starting
with soy is kind of the benchmark Beauty
caste level you know pea has a similar
beauty caste level one is pretty good an
extrusion um usually low allergenicity
sometimes non-gm which can be important
for entering European markets protein
from canola from grapes use actually
very good but it has limited
availability in terms of getting protein
isolate other pulses have lower Beauty
categories but can be in some cases
combined to reach the point of soy we're
looking into into hemp protein as well
sunflower protein powders that can reach
up to 50 percent protein
corn and oats that are usually lower
lower nutritional quality at lower
protein concentrations there's one that
I like because they have chosen the name
for o team just very clever of them and
that's a fifty percent protein
concentration that's mostly used in so
we're looking into a kind of other
sources of protein with the idea that
we've only looked at maybe eight percent
of the total available crops it could be
used for plant protein and so we don't
know for certain that those eight
percent that we've looked at and
characterized are going to be the best
in terms of mimicking either a
nutritional functions of animal protein
or the structure and formulations of
animal protein products so some of the
other kind of underutilized or neglected
crops that we're looking at for sources
of plant-based protein just based on the
protein content of the mind itself
winged bean protein has about thirty
five percent protein in the seeds
lentils about twenty five percent
protein by mass and they also have very
good gelling and emulsification
properties drive
being 25% protein good with ability good
foam stability dry cow pee these have up
to 25% protein in these form good
emulsions lupins have high protein
content as well and they have favorable
properties compared to sleeping so may
be able to replace some of the soy
protein in products that we're using
with Lupin protein some others that have
been characterized less well Bambara
beans have a relatively high protein
content dulse which is this kind of red
seaweed I'm gonna talk about a project
that studies red algae that can have
between 9 and 25% protein by dry weight
but is one of the main kind of
aquaculture sources of plant protein um
mesquite beans and then duck weed which
is traditionally consumed as a
high-protein food source has a higher
protein content than soy beans but
doesn't have very good characterization
of its functional properties so we're
trying to fund research into extracting
protein from duck weed and looking at
functionalisation out of that as well
one of the projects that were funding in
the US with this company called trophic
is looking at deriving protein from red
seaweed from macro algae so the supply
chain for red seaweed right now there's
about 18 million tons produced and has
up to 45% protein in the plants we think
that would be a good candidate for plant
protein products as well as because it
has this kind of umami like flavor
profile and because it's red and so
people expect sometimes expect like beef
or other kind of meat products to have
that coloring and so being able to have
that in the client itself as a secondary
extract the key challenge here is
developing an extraction process for
extracting the protein from doles that
meets cost and quality targets so this
group is trying to optimize their
protein extraction processes to meet the
quality specifications of some of the
secondary companies that want to make
based protein products out of these
seaweeds we also look at
other types of non animal cell culture
so I won't talk about here but we're
also looking at using bacterial proteins
for micro proteins sometimes in
conjunction with my base proteins as
natural sources both of a protein itself
and of flavorings stabilizers pigments
so most of the projects that were
funding in this area have the aim of
improving the nutritional profile of
crops in plant-based meats either using
selective breeding or genetic
modification to breed mice with higher
nutrient levels or higher protein levels
so we can get protein extracts more
easily get higher quality protein
extracts either for dietary supplements
or plant-based meat another project that
we funded with the foundation for food
agriculture and the open flan 3 project
is trying to optimize the use of pulses
based meat so along with identifying new
or underutilized sources of crops that
we can use we can also optimize crops
that are currently it used to be better
for my face need to increase the amount
of protein in them we're doing boosts
the bioavailability of them this project
is characterizing the texturization
abilities and molecular
characterizations of pulse proteins
including where they bind other
molecules like flavor agents how they
unfold during the cooking process and
computationally which genes can be added
or edited you needs to produce varieties
improved in this area um this is too
many words on one slide basically the
research process were in phase 1 the
using high-throughput digital
phenotyping and sequencing to
functionally characterize a variety of
pulses with a focus on Galatian
water-holding capacity and fat binding
ability which are important for making
my based burger or product that's going
to be a kind of a mixture of this
protein slurry and some kind of
plant-based fat and they're also looking
at the structuring ability of proteins
from pulses or in these ingredient
combinations to form a fibrous structure
that looks more like it more like tissue
that would kind of have this meat like
appearance and texture so all of this is
going to be publicly available online so
that in the second phase they can use
that data to perform breeding to improve
pulse crops for the explicit purpose of
making these crops
better based meat ingredients
cultivating them for that based meat
applicant obligations so there's an
entire pulse
Council
that is supporting this and the things
that one of the ways that they can
improve the market for pulses is by
selling to kind of a growing plant-based
meat market this exemplifies some of the
ways that we're trying to make data
collection and analysis available to
researchers more broadly us that we can
have kind of a database of what crops
are best for plant-based meat which
genotypic and phenotypic characteristics
lead to higher protein high protein
expression levels so that people can
then go on and do studies based on that
where they're trying to optimize other
maybe crops or other plants that we
haven't identified as potential sources
of land-based meat or do something
studies were talking about like with
soil condition to see which
characteristics and improve the
bioavailability of the proteins in these
crops one another of the projects that
we're funding that's kind of similar to
that is looking at fermentation of oat
protein application analog so
fermentation can improve the flavor of
protein it can produce additional lysine
which is one of the problems with
protein as it has a limited amount of
lysine that reduces its PD cows for both
protein also has some anti nutrients
some lectins and saponins that can be
degraded through fermentation
fermentation can produce exit
polysaccharides that improve the texture
of the oat protein and it can increase
overall nutritional value so this group
in estonia is looking at exploring how
fermentation can affect the quality of
oat protein and make a better oat
protein in terms of flavor
other ways that we can increase protein
yield and so this was not research that
we funded this was just a paper that we
thought was interesting and exemplifies
some of the ways that we can improve
protein yield not just through targeting
protein itself but also targeting client
growth and so this project was trying to
improve photorespiration
so that plants so that the main the
primary process which is in gray
involves the kind of expensive break
down like late in the they were trying
to engineer other actually processing
mechanisms it would reduce kind of the
time and the cost of the plant of doing
that and they found that this greatly
increased growth of the plant though
it's unclear whether that is passed on
to subsequent generations
the main idea here is that we are also
looking for research projects that would
improve yield of plant proteins in terms
of increasing the size of rodent
research
shortening the growing time as well and
not just increasing the protein
concentration in seeds and leaves
so once we've then chosen a plant that
we want to use in a plant protein
product and we need better methods to
isolate and functionalize the raw
materials for making punish me
documentary better methods of protein
fractionation or isolation isolation as
well as enzymatic functionalisation
biologically or chemically and
hydrolysis so we can either look at
chemically isolating the raw material
that we want to use we can look at using
mechanical methods to separate the raw
materials we can look at soaking and
using solvents milling or pounding to
isolate various components to the plants
using enzymes and extruders to
restructure the plant proteins that they
exhibit some of the same functional
properties that we want in animal
proteins and many of these can be
optimized for plant-based meat raw
materials to improve digestibility
texture when we talk about what type of
plant protein we want to use in some
cases we want to use protein flour in
some cases protein concentrated protein
isolate these vary based on protein
contents and based on how they're
fractionated what kind of use so the
process by which soy protein is produced
from soybeans can kick out either so
flour soy protein concentrate or soy
protein isolate at these different steps
the soybeans themselves are cracked and
behold the holes that can be used as a
product themselves as a few probably
themselves when they're flakes and then
you can get soy oil from that and so
there's kind of a multi-step process
depending on what concentration of
protein you want to get from the soybean
and then similarly in wheat a multi-step
process depending on whether you want
quite a wheat gluten in your products
whether you want textured wheat protein
isolated wheat protein and what kind of
concentration of wheat protein what so
optimizing this process and looking at
other types of extrusion methods that
can either involve lower temperatures or
they involve higher pressure instead of
asthmatic extrusion or hydrolysis could
improve the texture and can improve the
functionality of
the results on protein um high-pressure
huh modernization in particular we're
looking at because we know that taste is
better in products that have a higher
protein concentration but we're not
entirely sure whether that's because the
processing steps that are used to
improve that he's going to fraction
eight out the plant protein involve
higher heat so we're looking at whether
higher pressure can end up with a high
concentration protein product that has
the same kind of lack of taste it
doesn't involve that heat treatment step
from there we want to make a formulation
from this plant protein product and that
involves adding binders adding
flavorings adding plant-based fats
cements adding other ingredients that
will improve the taste or smell of the
product so in terms of recapitulating
the experience of cooking when we're
looking at additives that are going to
be flavor and fragrance additives we
need something that's going to be stable
throughout the cooking process and that
was also going to retain that same
flavor and a fragrance profile from a
raw product through a cooked product so
one of the reasons why impossible foods
decided to launch their burger in
restaurants first was because they could
then kind of control the way that the
end product was presented to consumers
and the beyond burger being available in
grocery stores you can take it home and
open it and a lot of people complain
that it smells like cat food or that it
has this kind of like off scent in its
raw or natural form so there's a course
at Berkeley that I advise and we work
with Shiva down on developing new
flavoring agents for that base meat
products and some of the interesting
things we find it at some of the
molecules that were looking at like
there's one two methyl five butylene
that smells like citrus at low
concentrations and smells like chicken
at high concentrations and the idea is
how can we control the concentration
profile of this chemical when we're
adding it to a formulation that people
are then going to cook at home or make
into he falls at home another main
component of optimizing flavor is adding
so we'll talk about heme in terms of the
impossible burger and how they've used
soy like hemoglobin to recreate that
kind of irony taste of the bloody
components of meat
flavor also involves adding fat and so
one of the projects that we're funding
at Berkeley involves encapsulating
sunflower oil in a commercially
available Sapan in and then planful
izing freeze drying that's but it can be
used as a shelf stable additives and new
formulation you can have oil that you
want it to be encapsulate encapsulated
in some way because you want it to
retain its position within the overall
kind of structure the product through
the cooking process so ground beef has
40 different types of fats that have
different melting points and different
levels of saturation and so throughout
the cooking process they'll melt at
different stages some of them will
remain solid at the end of the cooking
process some of them melts the very
beginning when you're adding a
plant-based fat you're pretty much
adding one type of fat molecule you're
adding you know sunflower oil you're
adding palm oil something and that has a
particular melting point so it's one of
the challenges is finding ways of of
encapsulating that fat such that it will
remain solid throughout the cooking
process it doesn't immediately just leak
out and you end up with a very dry my
face burger um
flavor kind of all flavors in plant
proteins are one of the main problems
for my based meat as well so we have a
project that we're funding in China it's
trying to identify what molecules are
responsible for these kinds of beanie
off flavors better present and key
protein to identify which volatile
compounds contribute to that beanie off
flavor and then figure out ways of
removing moving those compounds so this
is primarily a project that's using GC
mass spec to first identify which
volatiles are contributing to that off
flavor and then see if they're easy ways
of extracting that through the process
of producing P pretty nicely some of the
other technical obstacles to formulation
include that in muscle phosphates can
draw protein from the meat matrix or
from the muscle to the surface and that
can create kind of stickiness and help
with forming a coating on top of the of
the meat product as it's cooking we're
not sure if just adding phosphates to
plant-based meats is going to do is
going to have the same functional
properties a lot of times we add
starches to find basement products as
binders that can affect the mouthfeel of
the products and then we need to combine
them with fiber in order to have a
better
texture and better nutritional
properties fiber itself though absorbs
water and so that can also affect
mouthfeel even though it's an effective
texture replacer for fat you don't wanna
have to high of a fiber concentration in
your products because then that leads to
more water absorbing product than you
may want so we can't fully replace
starch with fiber in the product you
have to figure out the optimal
combination of starches and fibers and
proteins they're going to make something
that has the same kind of bite and
chewiness of whatever meat product
you're trying to replicate the next step
then is manufacturing so taking this
mixture a probably plant protein some
kind of fats and flavorings and binder
and taking that slurry and processing it
and so that can include extrusion
molding dehydration shear cells fiber
spinning 3d printing as well as
developing the sensing technology so
that we can determine at which point in
for example an extrusion process we're
getting the right texture and under what
conditions we're getting the right
texture so a lot of plant-based mu is
produced through high moisture
twin-screw extrusion so this is kind of
a machine it would be about like the
size of something you'd put on a factory
floor like sometimes I put a person here
to show you that it's not like bench
scale kind of factory scale extrusion so
we put that premix kind of protein
slurry into a theater and then there are
co-rotating screws that are heated as
well so you can affect you can change
what type of protein comes out both by
the final dye that cools the product and
kind of cuts it into shapes but also by
the rate of rotation of those screws by
the temperature by the water
concentration the idea here is that we
want to produce a textured protein
similar to the way that v or spinning
machines were originally used to create
soy protein fibers we want to make soy
beans or soy protein into products like
soy curls or its products like any of
these variety of textures and shapes um
they're all soy protein and what we're
varying here is water content the dye
and the temperature used to extrude them
one of the other
we're funding is developing real-time
sensors for extrusion because we don't
really know when problems develop during
extrusion until they come out the other
end of the ice this could be a project
that would help us improve the cost of
diagnosing problems with protein
extrusion and also monitoring throughout
the process through ultrasonic
ultrasonic sensing within the actual
twin-screw itself we can see when we're
getting a better shape or when we're
getting better fiber structure um some
of what we do in order to help companies
develop these processes as well as you
kind of back to be on the ball
calculations or like economic monitoring
of what the scale they would need to
produce would be if we want to meet
certain targets of selling to selling a
certain amount of plant-based meat or
producing a certain amount um so if we
look at just time moisture twin-screw
extrusion we can look at how many
kilograms for our fund based meat can be
produced from the average extruder how
long they're run if we think that maybe
we want 80% of plant-based meat products
on the market in 2020 to use extrusion
then we know about how many industrial
scale extruders we would need to have
operating globally
knowing about the number of extruders
that are operating currently it's it's
fewer than 168 I think it's about 130 or
so so we would need to scale up the
number of extruders that are operating
one way we can do that is by encouraging
companies to have better monitoring so
that it's more economically feasible for
them to increase the amount of extrusion
that they're doing but another way is to
use other methods that are maybe gentler
that require lower temperatures in
extrusion so bargaining and university
and the Netherlands has developed
something they were originally calling a
Collette cell another calling it a shear
cell it's kind of like an ice cream
maker in the sense that it has this
large rotating ring in the outside a
static ring on the inside and you put
your protein formulation in the kind of
barrel and the difference in rotation
between the outer rim of the outer
rotating ring an inner static rim sets
up this shear gradient and that aligns
protein fibers in a way that helps the
mimic muscle fiber itself so this is
kind of what it looks like coming
out of the machine here are some
electron micrograph images of how the
protein ends up structured and this kind
of fibrous align sheets and here's what
something like the below image would
look like when cooked so it kind of
replicates the the texture and the
perception of fiber um in terms of these
processing methods we also look at how
processing affects both the chewiness
you can imagine that as you're rotating
and setting up this your gradient you're
mixing the protein more and maybe making
it should we're increasing insulation so
we look at how heat and pressure
throughout these processing steps
affects the hardness and the chewiness
in this case of rapeseed protein extract
so that we can target something that
most model more closely mimics an animal
protein that we're looking to replicate
there's also a company called Nova meat
that's looking into 3d printing as an
alternative to extrusion so it can use
an ink that's a paste of rice protein
pea protein and seaweed so you can add
colors and flavors and obviously this is
not something that's going to scale up
to meet you know the entire demand of
plant-based protein that we have but you
can produce custom-designed shapes and
so it's an alternative to extrusion if
you want to make something that is a
very particular shape or size so one of
the projects that were funding that's
looking at texture is looking at
creating different meat like textures by
a combination of microstructure
engineering and high meister extrusion a
day here is that they would form kind of
a plant protein matrix it's one type of
protein and then precipitate a second
protein over that so like a pea protein
precipitated over a week or over a soy
protein structure the idea is that this
would help form a fiber like structure
that's more similar to me then that's
kind of a fiber reinforced polymer
network with a fiber filler in this
matrix and then yeah their idea is that
different meats have different fibrous
textures and so they can better target a
texture that mimics fish with it mimics
beef or chicken through this
precipitation process of what proteins
are used currently then when we're
talking about the impossible burger in
the beyond burger on the apostle burger
at least 1.0 use primarily
protein and potato protein the beyond
burger mostly P protein and what's
unique about the super Gers or why we
consider these more like the engineered
my protein products is at least in the
beyond burger the use of beet juice for
color but more kind of interestingly in
the apostille burger the use of soil a
hemoglobin protein that they're actually
producing and picking up as stores in
this yeast and that was kind of a novel
ingredient for them to produce so like
hemoglobin just a bit so like hemoglobin
this globin protein what they're trying
to replicate is myoglobin in muscle
tissue or you know hemoglobin that
transports iron through the bloodstream
because it's an iron binding protein and
has this red color and it also gives it
that kind of bloody taste and so they
originally isolated this so that
hemoglobin from these rhizome ik nodules
on the fruit of the soy plant but that
extraction process was costly and
required way to large volumes of soy
root nodules to extract sufficient
quantities so they ended up expressing
it in yeast and that required them
actually to go through an entire process
of FDA approvals demonstrate that this
was not in fact a new product and that
this was safe for human health and so
they had to do some rat studies of the
soy hemoglobin extracted from yeast as
well as improving the yield that they
would get from that process originally
they were doing we were doing column
chromatography to extract that was also
too costly so they were able to then
improve yield step by step so they could
just use weight fractionation and kind
of have these much larger kind of
fermenters the kind of similar to what
you would see like in a in a facility
that's making beers that they could have
the gross of large quantities of the
yeast that then they didn't have to
recover the same they didn't have to
have that like the same standard of
recovery as they would from cosmography
um so if we know that the beyond burger
and
you know the beyond burgers using p
protein and we know that many
plant-based burgers are using that type
of protein another kind of economic
analysis we can do is figure out how
many acres peas we would need to grow in
order to produce enough protein for the
projected amount of plant-based meat
that we're going to require I mean 2030
based on
these companies so we can go through and
look at how much protein we get from PE
you know high protein varieties are
about 25% protein the project I talked
about an equi not maybe can increase
that but right now a 25% and we look at
what percent protein a plant based
product is and then we assume what
percentage of plant based means find you
you sweet pea protein as the predominant
ingredient goes through some
calculations to figure out how many
acres of tees we would need to have that
were just dedicated to producing a few
protein for plant based meat and so that
can help us project how we're going to
need to evaluate current land usage or
how we should encourage farmers to grow
more peas or sell cheese into the
plant-based meat market um another thing
I want to point out here is that both
the beyond burger and the impossible
burger use coconut oil beyond burger
also uses canola oil so one of the main
reasons for using coconut oil is that
it's solid at room temperature so you
get that cooking processor you can have
a fat that stays solid throughout the
process but when we do kind of similar
scaling questions like this and look at
the current um coconut oil market and
then project demands for coconut oil
just from plant-based meat we're going
to reach kind of peak coconut in about
12 years so we also need to start
thinking about how we can encourage
coconut oil producers to to grow more
coconuts more coconut oil assuming that
we're going to have similar demand
trajectories for the possible burger and
Beyond burger that you use this so why
do we think we're going to continue to
have similar to man trajectories for
these we do see increasing investment in
terms of both plant-based neat and clean
me um year over year in terms of both
deal volume and amount raised we can
break that out into plant-based meat on
the left as having raised the highest
amount um with a second highest number
of deals plant-based egg and plant-based
dairy close behind um clean make the
next thing dairy because we think that
those products are still you know at
least ten years out they've raised less
money in a more exploratory we see a lot
of funding going into the development of
my base meat both research funding and
commercial funding and what we also see
that's interesting is that a lot of kind
of traditional meat companies like Tyson
and Cargill are also investing in meat
with the idea that they want to be
protein providers and the
they're going to be multiple sources
from which people get their protein they
want to be part of that market not going
to be disrupted in that sense um so I
want to touch on some of the kind of
whitespace ideas in plant-based protein
that we are trying to find researchers
who are willing to work on because we
have this competitive grant proposal
process that we run every year we get
out five million dollars in grant
funding but really we give out as much
money as we can raise to give out
because we're a non-profit seed you know
research projects where we can but some
of the ones that we are interested in
people working on are like we talked
about increasing the yield and
robustness of crops that are used for
plant-based proteins adapting tolerance
to climate change to expand the regions
in which these crops can be grown and
expand their going profile um improve
the amino acid profiles have produced
more complete proteins in a different
variety of crops that we don't always
have to rely on soy and we want um that
complete protein improve the flavor
profile definitely so decreasing the
concentrations of saponins that can be
bitter isoflavone xand life oxygen aces
that can believe to those kinds of
grassy and beanie off flavors we think
that producing fats in algae would be a
good way to both utilize algae in terms
of extracting protein from it as well as
using it to produce an omega-3 or
amazing fatty acids um we're looking at
funding platforms that assess different
characteristics of plant proteins within
processed ingredient batches to increase
consistency of downstream processing um
when we do tests of P protein if we
imagine that we are like a plant-based
company we're trying to buy lots of
protein um for the most part they
include not just one varietal of peeve
they'll include multiple types of yellow
and some face is also a green pea
they're highly variable and they're not
from one particular growing region or
from one particular set of soil
characteristics or growth
characteristics so we want to be able to
improve the consistency of plant
proteins that are available so we can
improve the consistency of them the end
product when it's using something like
pea protein in terms of
functionalisation we're interested in
products that in projects that perform
customized processing of raw plant
protein ingredients to the specification
of a client's functionalisation desires
again the inconsistency in sight
proteins in terms of their functional
properties is a hurdle for companies
that are buying large quantities of key
protein and can't rely on on consistency
batch to batch and we are looking at
projects that remove or mask off flavors
and plant-based proteins that can
develop better tasting products kind of
the Holy Grail for plant protein is just
a protein it doesn't taste like anything
just hard to achieve and particularly in
something like soy we're looking at ways
to maybe mask those types of flavors in
plant-based proteins um looking at
developing new binders new plant-based
fats pre textured proteins and looking
at better methods of extrusion for
creating that fibrous nacinda
plant-based meat product better sensors
for monitoring quality of my base meats
through the extrusion process um some of
the opportunities they're also looking
at our our blended proteins um so like
sonic makes a blended burger that is
partially beef blended with mushrooms
and we think that this is a way that we
can get more plant protein ingredients
into consumer diets or we can have
something that's a blend of animal
protein and plant protein that will also
increase our ability to be 10 billion
people by 2050 and so the final kind of
call to action is if we look at global
R&D investment into renewable energy 11
when they said captured with a lot of
government funding a lot of private
funding we can see that a lot of the
money that was spent into developing
renewable energy went into types of
energy that aren't currently being used
or that weren't you know work feasible
we haven't we haven't been able to make
biofuels work but then if we compare
that to the amount of R&D that's gone
into meat alternatives or just about 1
billion you know we have plant base made
meat alternatives here and we really
think that with the addition of more
funding both governmental funding and
industry funding we'll be able to make
much better plant-based meat products
improve the development of these
products to address kind of a similar
environmental problem as renewable
energy has been developed to address
that's all from me we have one minute to
lunch questions I um I was wondering if
there's been any of looking into about
growing like protein based plants in
marginal environments because it's an
argument some people in the animal
science community make about you know
weird beef cattle are grazed yeah some
of the from the projects that we're
funding to look at like how soil
characteristics vary in environments
where there's a lot of growth is aimed
at that wondering whether we can get him
optimized some of these crops that they
produce at least like 25 percent protein
at soil conditions that normally
wouldn't be used for so we're looking at
that in in Israel and in Canada and in
India in terms of either soils varying
nitrogen concentrations or areas where
there's higher drought and looking at
some of these crops that can be improved
to be drought tolerant but still retain
about 25% protein um it's it's not ideal
but yeah part of part of the projection
of you know how many people are gonna
have to feed also includes under what
conditions are going to have to feed
them the idea that we're going to have
higher temperatures and more droughts
yeah that increases that the number of
areas we're going to have to grow these
crops so I know for some of the
plant-based milk products like almond
milk soy milk there's some controversy
about standards of identity and calling
it milk and so I'm kind of curious and
for the plant-based meats and these
other products this industry has been
around long enough that they haven't
come up with a better name the
plant-based meat but is there a centered
of identity conflict coming because
these products are very diverse
he comment on that at all yes these
products from using the term
meats and so we're kind of fighting that
bill but on the state level there are
kind of Cattlemen's Association groups
another like industry groups that are
trying to restrict the use of terms like
chicken or sausage or bacon for the most
part because there's been such a long
history of these products being sold
under the similar names we can say that
there's not consumer confusion but yeah
on a state level there are a couple of
different bills mostly in in states that
have like large ranching interests or
have a lot of food production like
Missouri in some of those event dates
where they're trying to restrict the use
of those particular like pork or chicken
or beef terms we haven't come up with a
really good alternative name so we just
kind of have to fight that legislatively
hello I wasn't sure if you might be
become at that but there's been work
done on trying to make a vegan cheese
sort of like a plant-based cheese
alternative but seems like there has not
been in much progress of taste does that
seem to equate to what milk-based cheese
can be done can you comment on that
what's available yeah I'm also like
privileged because in the Bay Area we
have access to all of these because so
many of these companies are
headquartered in the Bay Area and so
distribution problem but um most of the
problem with making a vegan cheese is in
like melt ability so we can get like
spreadable cheeses or something that has
the same kind of texture as like feta
cheese or something that's more like
crumbly but getting a plant protein it
melts in the same way and it retains fat
and the same way did Jerry cheese does
has been a problem but yeah there I
guess I feel like New York owes does the
best there's also like light life that
has some of these diets like a shredded
plant-based cheese active R&B terms of
making better melting very high so there
seems to be a trend within the food
industry away from processed products
toward clean label foods just a new
point
sustainability yeah it's something that
face or the kind of industry struggles
with as well as nutrition because I mean
they both be on burger in the impossible
burger like have similar fat content to
a ground beef rigor and they're not
necessarily marketed it's like a health
product they're just mark that
something's supposed to replace product
and yeah for the most part anything that
that we're making is highly processed as
you can see like the protein extraction
13 extrusion um process itself category
so for the most part based on the idea
that when we do survey is about like 1%
of the us will admit to being vegetarian
and lying that's a relatively small like
target market so for the most part what
these companies are trying to do is get
people who are poor kind of words
reflect Aryans to like try this product
that's just going to be a substitute in
terms of taste and price and not looking
as much into replacing like the less
processed foods that represent a smaller
proportion of the market um it's it's
definitely a concern for like a lot of
people that I work with because when you
use when you work at a think tank of
supports there's like a lot of people
that I work with are vegan or vegetarian
and are also concerned with like
concerned with food processing and with
eating hard rock but I would say that's
still relatively Anish concern as
compared to taste lower down on the on
the consumer checklist in terms of
choosing what to buy okay you mentioned
that yeast fermentation improve the
enticing content of most protein does
this work for meat and Wadley - I mean I
I don't see why it wouldn't but we have
in if you would like to study that apply
to our program just fall wait yeah I
mean so one of the problems with Oh
protein that they're trying to improve
is the profile and so that's relatively
unique to terms of the lower levels of
lysine some of the happenin content is
not present in wheat but there's nothing
to say that
wouldn't improve the taste profile of
wieder barley as well when we're looking
particularly in terms of how well
thinking of these plant-based protein as
a consumer product the price that he has
is it mostly to you because he's
actually that complex to make crazy
because it's new and the company needs
to survive so I'm kind of curious how
the price would compare if like meat was
price as expensively as it should given
all the inputs that it needs yeah I
would actually compete in that weird
yeah I mean all companies are aiming for
price parity the beyond Berger is
probably like a dollar so per burger
more expensive than ground beef um some
of it is to recap R&D costs some of it
is because the processing steps are more
involved but I some of the cost also
comes from the the fat they need to add
to it in terms of the prices coconut oil
um but as they're able to scale up and
so like other increasing the size of
their facilities that price should come
down and actually when both beyond and
impossible did a lifecycle analysis of
the product they found that not only one
of the main contributors to to water use
into greenhouse gas emissions also know
the main contributors to price was the
packaging materials that they're using
to look into better and also more
biodegradable just trays and kind of
plastic wrap so they can sell it in a
way that it looks like it's packaged
like it's ground beef but and something
that's more easily recyclable because
that ended up being one of the primary
so that like packaging is also so so it
seems like there are many issues that
could be helped with genetic engineering
I mean things like hydrogenation levels
of non coconut oils and and fats and
stuff like that is that something that
you guys are actively trying to stay
away from so can't can somebody out
there make synthetic
you know make canola make coconut oil
ideally yeah yeah I mean I tell you'd be
able to so that's one of the projects
trying to look at algae as a way that we
can produce some of these fats exogenous
Li um
cost is probably still going to be an
issue but yeah hopefully we can use some
kind of platform like like a user
bacterial platform to produce are there
any other so in terms of nutritional
quality you showed a graph of the
different iron contents of some crops
that people are using for these plant
based beets are they also measuring
phytate levels to try to get at maybe
some of the iron bioavailable
bioavailability issues that might come
with plants replacing meats yeah yeah
particularly and and in general just the
bioavailability of the protein in the
plants that we're trying to engineer to
have higher protein content and like so
in the pea study we're not just trying
to increase the percentage of protein
available in the dry pbl so than the bio
as its processed or cooked because we
don't want to increase the protein love
increase the protein concentration but
not be able to then extract that version
yeah that's also part of what economists
question do you think that food will be
affordable in 2050 if we use this method
because it's a very expensive process so
I believe we'll have available food but
do you think it will be affordable that
time yeah is a concern that we're also
looking at how how the cost of producing
livestock might increase as we're either
as either the crops we used to feed the
livestock increase in price or as we're
running out of room as in the case with
like fisheries we're running out of
coastline that could be leased so we're
both trying to reduce the price of
based me and also looking at maybe some
kind of like intersecting purple prices
where we would see the price of animal
meat increase and the like the least
expensive way to eat would just be to
eat some of these vegetables and pulses
and grains like on their own and not try
to make them into something like the
beyond burger the impossible burger um
the idea behind those is that we want to
to replace something that's a Gregorian
efficient something that is hopefully
yeah as price is a concern like we can
oh we have that graph of the different
protein levels and protein sources like
yes you can meet your daily protein
requirement just with vegetable proteins
and those are cheaper than animal-based
proteins yeah from from a purely
economic standpoint like sure don't buy
the impossible burgers buy like rice and
lentils and however you like with other
vegetables we want to replace we have
one final question from zoom and your
bell D asks besides the process of
fermentation are you also looking into
improving the quality of the protein of
these crops by GM or other means that's
what they are yeah yeah so like some of
the studies that economists doing are
looking at improving the the
concentrations and availability of that
protein also improving the GM is one way
to do that and the particular like oak
protein project is just looking at
fermentation because they're a lab that
studies fermentation so they had this
idea that fermentation because like an
easy and cost-effective way to uh to
improve the completeness of the protein
and to decrease the concentrations of I
supply bones and saponins in the
oportunity racks but so
another lab may be able to improve oat
protein in a different process all right
can we all join and thank Elsa this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu